i think it's really great that you still
enjoy martial arts even after you're
done fighting
like you still love to train and improve
like we were talking about how the fact
that you just trained with freddie roach
and before this we were talking about
how you're gonna go to puerto rico and
train with the donahue death squad like
you're going to go down and train with
those guys
you're literally going to go to a
[ __ ] island to go do jiu jitsu
you know i i like
the confidence that martial arts
give me because i i i started when i was
very young
and it saved my life you know because i
i started when i was bullied
uh in in school and
it became it became a habit and if i
don't do it i'm not happy and i
don't feel confident i remember
when i was a kid i was looking at myself
in the mirror
and i didn't like myself i didn't like
what i
what i saw in myself because i wanted to
change my environment
and martial art taught me that
if you want to change your environment
you want to change yourself you need to
love yourself first
and i learned how to love myself i
didn't love
right away in the beginning who i was
but i love
who i could become and i wanted to
become that person that i visually
visualize the idea george saint-pierre
that i could become
that's when i start training and that's
when i start
looking at people in the eyes instead of
looking down and when i shake someone's
hand
i a firm grip and i when the teacher was
asking a question before i was always
like this
always the last to answer now i was
taking charge hey i know the answer five
plus
five it's ten for example yeah i i
exteriorized myself i got out of my
comfort zone
and it start building up my confidence
and
you know like in in life the bully it's
like a predatory animal
it will never hunt the strong alpha male
it will go
for the week and it's the same thing so
i wish i could tell you i get out of my
bullying because i kick all their ass
because i've learned karate but that's
that's not how it happened it happened
because i gained confidence
and by gaining confidence i became
someone different
i became a different person and that's
why i like to go to puerto rico to train
because if i don't have martial art
if i walk to a place perhaps it's the
remnants of what happened in the past
for me i will not feel confidence
maybe it left a scar in my mind i don't
i'm not a psychologist but maybe perhaps
that's what a psychologist
will tell me because it
left a big scar in but i think that scar
is a gift
it could be i think it is with you
because i think that scar
forces you to continue to grow and learn
and even though your
your competitive career as a
professional and as a champion
may or may not be done depending on
whether or not dana white shows over the
check
it shows up with a good check and at the
right time
so the money and the timing they know
very important
very important show up at wild card gym
while you see him in the southwest dance
but even if that doesn't happen what's
what's important is that
that gift makes you constantly look to
improve yourself
and yeah because you know the benefits
of that they they even though like you
would think
like people listening to this go wait
wait wait george st pierre is a
confidence thing
like you're the [ __ ] one of the
greatest of all time if you have like a
list of like the mount rushmore of
great martial artists you're on that
that mount rushmore man
but still you're honest and you're
honest about
your your feelings on these things and i
think it's a very important thing for
people to hear because
there's a real great benefit for anybody
in challenging yourself it's a great
benefit
and it doesn't mean that you have to be
a world champion does it like as a
martial artist
comparing yourself to who you used to be
is what's important who were you last
week and who are you now are you
growing are you getting better are you
learning new skills because if you're
not you're doing it wrong
you're supposed to you're supposed to be
challenging yourself yeah yeah i i think
that's the biggest benefit for me
um you know like like and it helped me
love myself you know what i mean i like
to to be fit i like to be in good health
and uh that's what martial art taught me
and it's something that changed my life
you know that that's one of the benefit
of course
if you look at competition in mixed
martial art you know sometimes it has a
very
uh you know violent ending but
what it can brings to an individual it's
so much you know it's so much more
positive than
the the what you see sometime on tv and
i think it would benefit the bullies too
i've always said like people say like
what's the best way to stop bullying
well teach everybody how to fight
because a lot of the reasons why the
bullies do it because they're looking
for some sort of external validation
they're looking to dominate people to
make themselves feel better but if they
could just learn
martial arts the the people that we know
that are good at martial arts are some
of the nicest people in the world
yeah like jiu jitsu people in particular
they're so nice
most people that i know that are just
[ __ ] stone cold killers
they're so friendly they're so nice you
know i i grew up in canada and i feel
very lucky to grow up in canada but it's
not some time because you grew up in a
nice
place that nice things happen you know
what i mean
everybody can face different adversity
and i and
and i think it's important to to love
yourself to accept yourself as a person
if in order to change your your your
your surrounding
and and then it's very important in life
and in
everything you know like if you want to
if you want to do good
you have to to look at yourself in the
mirror and accept who you are and who
and try to be who you want to become yes
you said it
at once i i believe you said you know
we talk about loving yourself sometimes
you love yourself a lot
a lot sometimes you don't right because
we all do things that we regret
sometimes nobody is perfect sometimes
i look at myself in the mirror and i'm
like man i just did something very
stupid i don't really love myself
sometimes i love myself a lot but you
said it like you're not the person who
you
are who you were in the past you're the
person who you are now
and and and i remember i've learned that
from you and
it was a great code that inspired me and
it's the truth
because we all learn you know sometimes
we talk about someone oh i don't want it
but that person is not the same that you
met
in the past he perhaps is different
perhaps it's better
it's he's better or maybe he's worse
yeah maybe he's worse
that's right yeah you have to
internalize that that you just because
you've made mistakes
you are not the person who you were when
you were at your lowest mistake
you have to realize those mistakes
although they're very painful they're
very valuable
because they teach you how you not how
you want to never be again
if you don't experience yourself at a
low point you don't know how bad it is
like you have to experience those bad
moments you know like oh i'm capable of
complete total failure
that's right like now i have to i have
to like never allow myself to get to
that place again and
for many fighters there's there's
fighters where they quit
in a fight and then they they always
quit
but some fighters quit they're like i'll
never [ __ ] quit again yeah
and they grow stronger because of that
so sometimes people say well once a
quitter always a quitter i say
[ __ ] that's right because some some
guys have quit and because of that
they're more dangerous than ever
because they had to go home and live
with themselves because of that quitting
and they [ __ ] hate it
so they train harder than ever and
they're terrified of that weakness
so they're horrifying fighter to face
because they've
faced the worst possible feeling you can
feel sometimes the worst feeling you can
face as a fighter is not loss
but failing yourself knowing that you
could have done
more but quitting